et pourquoi on est comme ça pourquoi on
est comme ça tout simplement parce que
je vous demander de regarder la fiche
d'eux on l'enlève le haut alors on
enlève l'otc trade marks de rebelles
bien entendu le film avec audrey lamy
qui nous rejoint dans un instant
regardez la fiche
voilà on peut la voir la fiche vous
plaît parce que je ne vois pas là je ne
sais pas où on en est voilà non mais non
mais non mais non
voilà celle du 13 voilà le puisque c'est
de maquiller dans les bleus au cas
exactement rebelles ça sort demain avec
audrey lamy
alors je ne vois rien sur ce tracé même
pas on est audrey lamy qui est avec nous
ce soir applaudissements pour elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les mecs le public n'a pas pleuré après
tout ce sont deux êtres hodder faudrait
on est très très très content de te voir
pour audrey tu sais que je t'adore la
dernière fois qu'ils étaient venus tu
sais que on est très bonne puisque le
film pour lequel tu étais venu le voir
la dernière foire avait avait avec tes
amis sdf cartonne il a cartonné déroulé
d'un million d'entrées amis voilà les
invisibles
vous êtes un ami non c'est un carton
c'est génial donc j'étais on était hyper
content hélas une fois de plus moi aussi
je suis je suis fan de toi j'étais
encore revu ce week-end dans ma robe
parce que c'est un de mes films préférés
ah bon c'est marrant comme un ouf sur ce
film ne serait pas appelé c'est pas
maintenant
voilà de quoi manon est ce moi tu l as
rome en fait j'aime bien si vous n'avez
pas vu ma robe mais c'est exceptionnel
je suis conseiller vous référer au monde
mais pourquoi on perd tout chez lui six
fois je te lis je connais tous les bacs
les enfants ils sont comme des oufs sur
le t zen à leur idole ces malades comme
aussi bonne que je fasse des tartes au
kk et tout je crois que t'as pas non
plus value des solutions d et c'est vrai
que tu kartonn et on est hyper fière de
toi parce que tu peux tout jouer mais
c'est encore dans rebelles tuent nous
montre encore une autre facette un
géraldine aller de il est génial
extrapolons des récompenses métrage
super moderne est du côté enfin côté
tarantino et thelma et louise trahi les
adorer fils esthétiquement c'est super
bien écrit super bien monté et tout et 3
vous êtes juge également en juin plus de
problèmes
y'a ya juste un gars dans plus qu'elle
peut enlever son sacré alors ya un gars
dans quels cas pas levé son sac
c'est l'invité mystère parce que c'est
l'invité mystère ah oui tu crois ici ça
bosse il faudrait un ami dans un instant
tu vas voir est l'invité mystère je peux
te dire tu vas être comme une folle
c'est pas mon europe n'en attend
calmement
alors tu vas voir une minute pour le
trouver audrey on va juste regarder
d'abord la bande annonce du film et
après tu auras une minute et on a même
des extraits exclu c'est d'ailleurs à la
production et après tu vas voir une
minute pour trouver de qui il s'agit
cette personne s'est invité mystère qui
est dans le sac c'est parti ford annonce
c'est vraiment canon disais tout le
monde se joue maintenant
[Musique]
les morts on a bien vu merci
le problème c'est qu'il faudrait soir
tandis y est et on peut le sentir petit
à petit
[Musique]
jean rémy disparaît avec le pognon des
belges mais pourquoi tu leur appendice
qui con quoi tu veux te fasses écrite
avec ma [ __ ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce que je pense
nolan roux audrey lamy et audrey tu sais
que je kiffe cette petite pop à la
corniche haleine mais toi aussi tu as
bien qu'elle aime sept coups mais je te
jure que j'adore je vais garder et ses
proches alors en fait il me faut se
range de moi et mes cheveux j'ai juste
ça devant hyperburo mais je voulais
absolument changer de tête
oui mais c'est réussi mais là tu fais et
allan mauduit le réalisateur voulait
absolument le choix blonde et moi je
voulais une brune donc on a trouvé à la
cia compromis quoi son coût de vue où
trouvent refuge à des compromis alors
cédric 6ème et là oh là là on aime bien
quand il est là était sa séquence
voilà alors on a un invité mystère pour
toi outre et ce soir c'est le jeu
connect du jour il va répondre que par
comme ça ou par comme ça comme ça 25 ans
tu vas pouvoir le trouver en une minute
qui est l'invité mystère qui n'a pas
enlevé son sac ce soir audrey c'est
parti on part pour une minute tu lui
poses tout une pause toutes les
questions qu on se connaît
personnellement oui c'est comme ça est
ce que est ce que vous êtes acteur oui
c'est un homme non auparavant il s'est
dressé bonne non non c'est non humoriste
qui ont ce que vous habitez à paris non
non non vous habitez à alès nancy c'est
mon père qui habite à alès s'est pas
fait ça je peux alors vous pensez que
c'est qu'il ya un gars est votre père
comme ils s'appellent michel bas de mon
lit ici s'appelle michel laplénie ciel
c'est votre père
[Applaudissements]
la frontière
venez vous asseoir et franchement audrey
à chaque fois que tu viens tu fais
pleurer ça tient lui il a dit lui aussi
est franchement merci à michel d'être là
michel dhrey connais votre micro
attendait surtout retenir ça va mais
michèle merli a caché son jeu en plus
pas ou alors dites nous parce que je
dirais que vous avez disent que c'est
mon repos mais quand même parce que
madame quoi après monsieur tu vois et
michel merci d'être là oui tu ne connais
pas ce matin la vérité est michel
franchement vous êtes un amour d'être là
et franchement on croyait pas du tout
que voilà que michel a dit réal et
répondent oui on s'est dit c'est vrai
que c'est une super surprise pour des
parce que trop bas on a un déficit à
chaque fois qu audrey bien on doit la
faire pleurer c'est la règle d'or à
aulus pébereau surpris et vous fait
pleurer le pape a aussi neds et oui vous
annoncions pour faire venir d'autres non
vaud est ce que vous êtes comme les
papas vous regardez tout ce qu'elle fait
enfin comme beaucoup de choses pas
toujours vous regardiez donné l'âge n'a
surtout pas
oui bien sûr bien sûr vous à vous avez à
vous avez vu robben le film deux fois
deux fois déjà
oui c'est vrai alors vous avez vu il
faut maromme je crois la mare à monsieur
voulions ce le fait ensemble un jour
c'est frais c'est parti j'ai été
prévenue combinant 12h30 comprendre la
crainte qu'un joueur se serait en plus
alors si on fait ça on se fait un golf
en somme un jour ce qui paraît que vous
êtes un bon golfeur pas un bon golfeur
un golfeur s'est fait alors
audrey entre combattants rebelles
mercredi mais ton papa il n'est pas venu
les mains vides parce qu'il nous a menés
des photos de toi inédite
ouais ce soir si vous passez une bonne
émission avec nous alors je les découvre
avec toi vous nous amenez quoi alors ah
oui ah oui ça c'est à ben oui ouais ça
la balle est allé tranquille ça la ja
vichy allier la tribune voilà c'est là
il ya derrière il ya tout il ya tout à
huy à balla gaye al.yahia l'ex ans et
alexandra et c'est bon non c'est grave
ou dans une impasse du tout tu
plaisantes j'étais super mignonne thuram
en deux fois oui oui ouais bah c'est
assez alexandrie alexandra les manifs en
france ce soir c'est alexandra est
magnifique elle j'aurais a changé et
aucune aucune bao audrey la série contre
elle amène tout est en fait la g tech
toujours au ladakh où la wii mais vous
gardez tous beaucoup de choses une des
premières une belle tournée jour ça
c'est des êtres humains ça que j'aime
les meurtres s&s about a reconnu c'est
vrai que c'est vrai vous avez on a en a
donc fondé l'an dernier et et je vous
demande et a pris franchement voilà
quand on a deux filles comme ça qu'ils
sont
son système est ce que comme beaucoup de
parents on vit pour elle c'est à dire au
jour le jour ce que vous faites voilà
vous vivez à leur rythme vous vivez avec
ce qu'elles font avec leur promo avec
les télés qu'elles font ou voilà vous
regardez on vit au rythme oui bien sûr
c'est vrai c'est ça ouais bah oui parce
qu'on partage leur passion de toute
façon donc on a été un peu or au départ
on attend donc la moindre des choses
c'est de suivre et puis on est passionné
de ce qu'elles font et du beau parcours
qu'elles ont bien sûr mais qui
aimeraient sûrement audrey mais qui
parce que l'état serait de vous être
très très drôle
vous avez un sens de la comédie in any
vous faites vous faites quoi dans la vie
ces célébrités dans la décoration
adacore merad avant que vous avez vous
déconner quand même un peu oui on
déconne bien je dis non mais c'est ça
passe audrey c7 c'est votre papa qui est
comme ça ouais tu ma mère aussi beaucoup
elle n'aurait pas osé est là ce soir ça
c'est sûr mais mais
mais on leur pique plein de choses alors
qu'ils plein de dominique de oued de mon
père en plus il vous dit ça mais c'est
vrai qu'il y beaucoup mes scénarios et
ouais on s'aime beaucoup a complètement
simple il a des très très bons conseils
et puis il est venu évidemment le voir
378,4 en faisant des notes et tout ça et
c'est souvent des très bonnes critiques
donc je me coupe beaucoup tout c'est
d'essayer d'être partiale et c'est vrai
que c'est pas toujours facile aussi nos
filles surtout mais enfin il faut il ya
que moi parfum parfois qui peut mieux
qui peut dire voilà ça c'est ça me plaît
moins ou et cetera il accepte très bien
vous c'est vous c'est votre père que
vous écoutez plus fins votre père votre
mère sur les choix ouais les trois
femmes
mon père ma mère et ma soeur est pas
vraiment ouais c'est une petite famille
mitre et ses déliés way